Stephanie starts off this hour in
Louisville Kentucky hi Stephanie how are
you I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's up yes we are on a baby
step number two and my husband right now
is contributing to his 401k and I'm
trying to convince him to stop doing
that temporarily and he just doesn't
want to because he doesn't want to miss
out on the match and I've tried to you
know tell him that we're gonna pay down
now so that later we can contribute more
and I'm just having a hard time getting
him to agree to that okay so um how
wealthy are you all we make about a
hundred thousand a year but how much
money is not that much saved up and his
401 he has probably around 16,000 right
now and then I'm a stay-at-home mom but
I worked part-time as well and I don't
know how much did we have about sixty
two thousand not including our house and
so you have what's called a negative net
worth do you know what I mean yes okay
and the man that has a negative net
worth has a financial plan your husband
uh-huh that's kind of like hiring a fat
person to be your personal trainer okay
that makes sense yes it does yeah so um
I mean he can do whatever he wants but I
don't hire someone to be my personal
trainer unless I'm going to submit to
their suggestions because they have an
eight-pack and I have a CAG great and so
I have to do what they say in order to
get to look like they look because my
method of eating two pounds of Oreos is
not working right your husband's method
of handling money
has a negative net worth knucklehead you
know yeah you can play this for him
later off you want to off the podcast
but I mean it's you know it at some
point you have to say I don't know how
to do this and so I need to do something
better than my best thoughts now let me
give you the explanation and maybe that
will help but until until knucklehead
determines that he doesn't have the
answers with his negative net worth on
how to build wealth I can't help him and
you can't either
okay okay but if you can get past
knucklehead ISM my wife has to deal with
not go ahead to occasionally so there's
no it's a part of life right I don't
think your husband's a bad guy I'm just
picking on him all right but it's just
kind of if you think about the logic
flow of it it's absurd for him to be
giving forth his financial wisdom given
that given that he has a negative net
worth okay so you're not on baby step
two you're on your and your husband's
version of something that looks sort of
like what we teach but what we teach is
if your own baby step two you have
stopped all investing temporarily while
you get out of debt and here is why how
long y'all been married seven years this
year how long did you date before you
were married about two years okay let me
tell you what you succeed at you succeed
at things you pay attention to the
reason he succeeded at making you his
wife was he paid attention to you right
the things you focus on are the things
you win at and right now he's focused on
two things one trying to work this weird
plan his wife has come up with this is
weird guy on the radio told her to do
and at the same time keep investing he's
dating two women uh-huh
angle work right the lack of focus is
what causes people to lose in not math
issues okay if his plan and if math
could fix your all's mess
it would have been fixed before you ever
heard of me but now the plan works
because you only date one girl if you
want to get married okay so right now
you're dating the baby step two girl and
you're completely focused on her and get
her out of debt and that means the
matching girl over here in the 403b
is no longer in the equation because
otherwise the other one is not gonna
have fun it's the focus you follow me
that you've what you focus on is what
people win at okay you have no chance of
winning in something if you don't focus
and that the power of that focus
supersedes the power mathematically of
his match for a one to a two year period
of time while you all get out of debt
I'm not suggesting he abandoned the
match for the rest of his life that
would be mathematical blaspheming right
but for two years focusing matters
because for two years he focused on you
and you ended up in the altar right
focus stop the 401k even though there's
a match I understand the math that's not
about math it's about what you pay
attention to is what you succeed at you
can wander into debt but it takes
extreme intense focus to get out you
cannot wander out of debt you can't play
both sides of the field you can't play
the field while you're getting out of
debt it's too powerful it's too magnetic
it's too big a part of our cultural draw
and so knuckleheads got to go I got a
negative net worth I'm gonna try a
different plan than mine and go all-in
go all-in for 90 days go all-in for six
months and see how it works submit
yourself to a different idea it's not
that it's my idea except that I've got
better fruit from my ideas than he does
from his regarding finance
things and not only do I have a positive
net worth but I've also led 30 million
people out of debt so I'll probably know
a little about this and so that's the
thing you gotta it's not me bragging on
me as no arrogance it's not that at all
it's simply this it's you if I'm gonna
hire an estate planning attorney I need
to listen to what he says understand why
he's saying it and then agree to do
different things than I used to do in
order to have a good estate plan same
thing same thing whatever it is you're
gonna bring an expert into your life
this is not a DIY thing ish is a wish
doing the baby steps ish is a wish
don't be an issue assure it doesn't work
this is the Dave Ramsey show